thank you to GF for sponsoring this
video our favorite brand to work
[Music]
with all right Terra take it away
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tera Ericson alongside Gregory Al who he
did a hand move and so did I we are
watching Monsters versus
Aliens how do you like that I loved it
that was great it good right I sound
like an alien you guys are going to go
at home go to fall asleep you go God I
can't get the alien tear thing out of my
head so you got to leave a like for that
you got to leave a comment and you also
got to not forget to ring the
P ring the bell that was weird see I
went to the alien mode for the song too
so you guys know wow I am talented see
he SE everybody was absolutely
absolutely going to use that word as
well thanks also to prepper for helping
us edit down these videos also if you
join patreon we call you super sexy
everybody loves to be called sexy right
when someone walks up to you you're like
you look sexy you're like yeah women
love it when you do that to them what
what i' thank you so much you hear that
guys it's never happened to me may you
just want to go up to Terra go up to
your own you look sexy your own This
Woman's going to be ay okay with that
I'm going to start cold sweating and go
thank you so much I don't even know what
to do with myself if you join patreon
Greg and John offer exclusive highlights
of watchs over there and also you can
sck up with your whole entire copy and
watch like basically the whole movie
with me and
Gregory anyway we should talk to the
patrons now right we should get into
this movie yeah sure yeah let's do the
patreon intro let's get
[Music]
it it's
DreamWorks hey we like the DreamWorks
movie we like the DreamWorks we like uh
you know the banana
[Music]
banana next week we should watch
that cool I love me some
aliens what a fun way to set the
tone I love watching animated movies
with
Tera cuz I go beepo
[Music]
beepo
all right is that a lone survivor or is
it a nope
yeah classic alien
score way to harmonize that was good
huh oh they're coming for us why do they
always land in like the Arctic yeah they
never land like in the city and if they
do they're trying to kill us that burger
looks
insane this movie was in
3D that's a cool point of view you might
want to check this one out uh pelomar
just picked it up looks like some type
of UFO and it's heading this way how
many times I have to tell you this UFOs
don't exist and we're never going to see
yourself a poop a lot you know holy
Jesus what do we do no one ever told us
what to do the only reason I took this
job is cuz you never have to do it
[Laughter]
looks like Modesto California I've never
been to Modesto I don't even know that
exists oh yeah it's a real place I
[Music]
repeat it's what it's like working with
Tera that's Greg every time I come here
yeah is true it's an emergency I have no
time and I haven't slept it's true
[Music]
is this person just snoring or
dying they're being watched right
now oh that's the voice behind the
camera right yeah
[Music]
okay oh okay it's 5:00 in the morning
hurry turn on the TV turn it on now wow
you look great for waking up at 5: in
the morning yeah 75° a perfect day to
stop by the old folk art and craft show
down at the fairgrounds or a perfect day
to marry Susan Murphy who oh I love you
baby I love you too
weatherman and Good Morning Modesto
Channel 17
[Music]
to I love re wither spoon that's that's
awesome Seth roken
yes you Lori cool great cast I know I
love recognizable voices hello everyone
attention attention Wilson there's like
so many TV show actors every name in
here is in this movie it's like a fairy
tale the weatherman and the weatherman
Paul R Paul rud is in this I can't even
pay attention to the movie this time
tomorrow I'm going to be in Paris
Derrick will become an anchor or a
foreign correspondent and we'll travel
all over the world honey my fingers are
[Applause]
crossed one thumb is shorter than the
other it runs in the family oh I didn't
even notice that your kids are going to
have
it oh
God Steven coar I just spent way too
much time with our parents don't worry
okay we'll be alone soon that's Paul
Rudd yeah there's been a slight change
of plan plans what we're not going to
Paris why not because we're going
somewhere better oh to the meteor Fresno
Fresno in what universe is Fresno better
than Paris
DK I've got an audition to become
Channel 23's new evening anchor Universe
oh God what a snooze she doesn't want to
live in Fresno now look about Paris it's
fine as long as we're together Fresno is
the most romantic city in the whole
world whole world this marriage is off
to a terrible start this isn't going to
work it's bad luck to see me my dress oh
come on you know I don't believe in that
stuff you'll believe in that I hope an
alien kills
him oh it's already happening me e
skyrockets to being a big reporter if he
covers this
is this how she gets white hair in
the poster yeah has to be oh that's her
on the poster I think think I mean I
just glanced at she had the poster girl
had short white hair or something Susan
where have you been I think I just got
hit by a meteorite every bride feels
that way on her wedding day not taking
notice at all of the man of scrapes and
dirt it the giant hole in the ground oh
yeah the Earth
[Music]
rumbling I think DreamWorks often puts a
lot of attention to detail on their
camera work yeah which which is what
makes him so
cool are we just rushing past the whole
meteor thing I believe so nobody nobody
felt the rumble
wow you're
glowing
oh no Susan you're like really glowing
you're
green she was just hit by a
[Music]
meteor oh my
oh my gosh what's going on what's
Happening Here it's a met is
her is she the
monster this is
impossible whoa you're ruining God's
house get out of there lady you keep
grown you're going to be in the nude
help
me report on it
Derek just get out of there
Derek here comes the Bri great shot damn
your wedding day it's her wedding day be
hurt Derek sus goodness you're okay
she's like King Kong where are you
people what are you
doing stop it be careful she is like
King Kong don't you know who I am please
no one knows who you are you're the
weatherman
sir it's really fortunate that dress
also expanded too
yeah
[Music]
Derek whoa It's coming right at me baby
why' you set the alarm we're in our
honeymoon she's still a massive freak
with a rude awakening awaiting
[Music]
her yo this movie is cool it's like a
full-blown sci-fi movie yeah it's kind
of like got stranger things Vibe when
they put 11 in an elevator and take it
down to the
basement what a perilous situation to be
in this the worst W ever their
honeymoon hello she's inmate
five she is a giant freak awesome
hello is there someone
there
yummy
they crafted together a massive spoon
for her I guess
so what is
that hello
e please Madam stop doing that
oh whatever mad scientist made you he
really went all
out
hi there
Rogan my back just kidding I don't have
a back forgive
him I don't
even I forgot how to breathe don't know
how to
breathe
in oh he's being
serious wow look at you I know what
you're thinking first a prison you want
to take down the toughest guy in the
yard well I'd like to see you try we
learn
it
Ninja that's me in every pilates class
I'm afraid we are not making a very good
first impression at least I'm talking
first new monster in years we couldn't
get like a wolf man or or a mummy just
you know somebody to play cards with oh
my God they've been in prison this whole
time might we ask your name Madam Susan
no no no we mean we mean like your
monster name like what do people scream
when they see you coming couch here
comes
Susan so the world that inhabits is like
a 1950s like sci-fi B
movie yeah
pulive oh an old slipper okay that's why
she got a goop of something please tell
me I just had a nervous breakdown at the
wedding and now I'm in a mental hospital
and I'm on medication it's giving me
hallucinations
oh there's something bigger than her
[Music]
what competition oh that's why she had
five she's the fifth one of them okay
don't worry about it who's a handsome
bud let me
out woh moners get back in your cell
this actually looks like it would have
been a really fun 3D
movie yeah the name is General WR Monger
I'm in charge of this facility now
follow me it is time for your
orientation it's really cool how they
can put it in her PO and make it still
seem tiny yeah and then when they get
closer to certain things it's it changes
into like the size of how she sees it
but then on the outside it still looks
very small it seems like it switches
back and forth is my point without me
being by it mhm I'm just a regular
person I'm not a danger to anyone or
anything three people
dead that's awesome oh
God amuses himself I want to go home
don't think of this is a prison think of
it as a hotel you never leave because
it's locked from the outside like
quarantine the government has changed
your name to
ginormica poor Susan ginor what a really
interesting setup for a character
especially an animated
movie take this wonder and they really
gave us the unexpected didn't they I
think a great way to portray a monster
is to see the wound from within them
that's true we're at the heart of the
matter right now Gregory ala take
Serious God it's great we got to see her
her birth into Monster Land I get it
it's a metaphor for being a woman
right let me explain it to
you man explain it please begin
reanimation
sequence reanimation yeah what is that
they're bringing someone back to life
quantonium has been located on a distant
planet
quantonium oh the trajectory of the
quantonium meteor has been traced to
sector
[Music]
72-4 Planet locally known as Earth so
you can travel into like Dimensions or
something I want it all every last drop
it kind of looks like a messed up
version of mega mind yes that's what I
was thinking freaking mega
mind gy nasty oh thank goodness it's the
police we weren't doing anything officer
yeah nothing at
all oh great sound design wait don't
leave me alone I like how he's the froed
one she's the confidence and his car
license weight says gy nasty I think
it's broken oh my
God she carrying
everything I love the commitment to
this
whoa that's a hell of an opacity
transition the president of the United
States has arrived I must approach it
alone this is all about peaceful
communication this movie is so much fun
it's
awesome oh my gosh it looks so pretty
they really know how to capture like
height and scale in this even though
it's not in 3D for us you can feel the
dimensions really well yeah
[Music]
okay this song probably came out like
what
25 I was 25 this song came
[Music]
out I don't understand what's
happening this is how he talks to the
aliens plays and dances all right you
got
through
yeah how would he know that would
work cuz he's the Pres
of the United States oh he's going to
get like killed isn't he maybe they just
like Talent oh dang it
nope oh it's going to
morph holy
tamale oh my God that looks
awesome light them
up even the soldiers are like from an
earlier era call
call I love how this is all taking place
at Golden hour so it's all really
beautiful in the background ET go home
oh my goodness what an fun touch to
actually spray paint that
on you're dropping papers there
buddy oh God the tongue too oh my God oh
no surprisingly P there is some crass
humor in here we need our top scientific
Minds on this get India on the phone can
we transport the United States to a
safer Planet I say we give this alien a
green card and make him proud to be an
American hang it all what's the
point
stop that button launches all of our
nuclear missiles well then which button
gets me a latte that would be the other
one
sir m
Mr
President not only do I have an idea
yeah from the buttan oh my God amazing
we need a hail mer P we need raw power
we need monsters suicide sad Mr
President say hello to Insectosaurus
nuclear radiation turned him from a
small grub into a
350t tall monster oh this is so cool
it's a fun little play on godsilla this
handsome fellow is Dr Cockroach PhD he
invented a scientific machine it's like
the fly and jackelin hide unfortunately
there was a side effect oh we call this
thing
Bob genetically altered tomato was
combined with a chemically altered Ranch
flavored dessert topping at a snack food
plant the resulting goop gained
conscious
he's like the blob her entire body
radiates with pure energy giving her
enormous strength and size cool oh we
already have an alien problem General I
don't think we need a monster problem
too you got a better idea
nerd oh sweet wedgie I propose we go
forward with your Monsters versus Aliens
idea thingy team of Misfits let's go
let's do it
have
threes he's like creature the Black
Lagoon yeah dud how are you doing this
you're the luckiest guy know yeah it's a
riffin like classic movie
Monsters they called me crazy but I'll
show them that looks like a light bright
guys what choice do I have if he can
make me normal or even 6'8 I can get out
of here I mean I should be in let me
guess Fresno oh my God yeah you're
that's a plunger on her chin
throw the switch doctor but but don't do
the laugh now you're going to feel a
slight pin what what if she gets bigger
probably
will toaster pizza
[Music]
box y am I small again I'm afraid not my
dear you may actually have grown she did
the more she absorbs nobody's leaving
nobody's ever getting out good news
monsters you're getting out until today
what about the blob can't The Blob just
like
yeah under door he should be able to
right this is San Francisco this isn't
far from my home you will not be welcome
back it's a little hotter than I
remember has the Earth gotten warmer
that'd be great to know that that'd be a
very convenient
truth that'd be a
convenient you didn't say anything about
it being huge hello welcome we are here
to destroy you we are here to destroy
you I'm going to turn that oversized tin
can into a really dented
oversized I love the setup of Susan so
much WoW could you look at the size of
that
fo I got him you guys I
got get to the City Link I'll catch up
with you as soon as I
can or maybe you'll have to catch up
with me it's got like a Vincent Price
mustache it's too thin for my
taste I really love her character she's
such like an underdog situation awesome
she's a fish out of water is what we
call
it
what oh my goodness you have the quantum
Quant Quant what yeah you have energy
that thing can't do anything to you
you're filled with the quantum Quantum
stuff the quantum physics stuff you've
got it inside your
[Music]
soul I would definitely be breaking into
that Tavern right
now what a great use of the structures
that's really
neat oh
no oh
ah she just
realized that's awesome you're going to
discover some awesome this mov awesome
skill sets here yeah it's great cuz
we're learning with Susan as
she becoming a
mon that's so cool that is awesome how
inventive yeah girl turning cars into
roller
[Music]
skates great action shots man
yep that
hurt the shots of this movie each one is
awesome yeah I know it's very well
crafted catch
[Music]
me oh
shoot uhoh no save the truck oh boy yeah
turn it turn it back over you got to do
it with your big monster monster
moves come on oh she's becoming a
hero
uh-oh
[Music]
H how teeth are like drills I hate it
they're like dentist drill
I don't want
[Music]
it yay an insect
guy e he's trying to kill me why is it
doing that why would
it yeah yes you've got power you're
[Music]
amazing now break
it that's a cool little sound effect you
can't crush a
cockroach oh my God who here we
go we have to get these people off the
bridge got
it move the dividers oh yeah you're
right oh my gosh she's becoming a real
leader she is getting a hard workout
right now you guys you can do
[Applause]
[Music]
this oh
whoa woo
[Music]
Who
oh what a way to be gory without being
gory cool that lower life form thinks
she can steal my quantonium oh it's h ey
moves say that's cool Susan is now too
strong you'll have to get in there
yourself better course to Earth I will
retrieve the quantonium myself I love
the attention detail that every eye
moves on its own and how is his coffee
purple I want it I want purple coffee oh
my goodness in his ear 3 weeks ago if
you had asked me to defeat a giant alien
robot I would have said no can do but I
did it you were positively heroic my
dear you're going from Susan to g
gigantis whatever gigantica I got that
right you'll be back to your old self in
no time so will I what happened to the
there isn't a jar in the world I can't
open stuff my associate is trying to say
is that we all think the new Susan is
the cat's
mil tell me exactly how this normal life
thing works with you being giant I'm not
going to be a giant forever Derrick
won't rest until we found a cure for my
my condition Derrick's moved on he's
self-absorbed he's already in Fresno
talking about the weather oh no he's
doing Nightly News but he's sleeping
with the weather girl I called it gor I
called your family to let him know you
were coming home thanks General she's
not going to like it terara
nope
Su Mom Daddy a they still love her
it's okay they're with me these are my
new friends Oh Derek I missed you so
much it's the only thing that got me
through prison I love you oh no that's
my mother you're suffocating
her I taste
ham e gross hi I'm benzos lazine by
carbonate or you can call me
[Music]
Bob or B Bob whatever you do do not
provoke them anyone care for an atomic
Gill Fizz let's go quite a oh
[Laughter]
noing everyone run for your
lives oh now they're breaking it down
that's
[Music]
great wait wait wait
wait ouch oh dear believe my last 3
weeks you just wouldn't believe
it wow you really are big I'm still the
same girl you fell in love with did just
destroy the Golden Gate Bridge well but
that was the only way I was going to
stop that giant robot did you ever think
I could do something like that no I
didn't I know that together we can find
a way to get me back to normal I have an
audience that depends on me so you
expect me to put all that on hold while
you try to undo this thing that happened
to you oh my god he's such a cherk also
I was like why is he working right now
when he knows his wife is out huge
somewhere but I'm not looking to get
married and spend the rest of my life in
someone else's Shadow oh God take him
and throw him off the building just do
it lightly oh flick him we don't want
him to die we just want him to be hurt a
little bit cuz he's jerk your parents
really know how to throw it down great
party one of the best I've been to since
I got out of prison I must have been at
a different party because that's not how
I interpreted
it and I think that Jello gave me a fake
phone
number we could save every city on the
planet and they'd still treat us the
same way they've always treated us like
Monsters you're like the Ninja Turtles
uh how is Derek is a selfish jerk there
was no us there was only Derek why did I
have to get hit by a meteor to see that
it's a metaphor I mean look at all the
stuff I've done without him fighting an
alien robot what that was me not him
you're right you could have done that
without being
giant you personally carried 250 coads
off of Coco Beach and still had the
strength to fight off the National Guard
and also the
Lifeguard Bob who else could fall from
unimaginable Heights and end up without
a single scratch link
[Laughter]
you Su this is where we get into the
versus aliens part of the
movie way to go insecto uh-oh oh
ow
oh no no
no they wouldn't no he can't be dead he
just got be
knous a poor insecto don't you close
those eyes don't you dare close those
eyes no no no no no no it's got to be a
fake
out oh new outfit I like it oh she looks
sexy and shimmery you must be
terrified that's like my name terrified
Teri strange isn't it it's not the first
time you really get around H they have
some interesting inuendo humor in this
yeah yes your enormous grotesque body
contains quantonium you destroyed San
Francisco used to get to
me your voice is grating on my ear Nubs
that's what Greg says to me every day
yeah try filming with her with the
headphones just fine don't bother that
force field is
impen what the flag
no oh yes girl so she's probably more
powerful than she realizes all she
needed to do was break up with Derek and
now she's
flying that should stop your puny oh my
God
H waa cool shots God
damn ha that's awesome wow the World
building of the ship is
[Music]
awesome I love how they switch this
sequence for the ector to be from the
alien afraid of the monster
yeah computer begin extraction
no I mean oh man no she's going to be
small again after loving her life oh
man now she's just little Susan she got
what she wanted but is it what she
really wanted no of course of course not
finally I can rebuild my civilization
you keep your slimy tentacles off my
Planet if you wanted to stop me you
should have done it when you possessed
the quantonium now you're nothing not
true there are innocent people down
there who didn't do
anything find her strength there were
innocent people on my home planet before
it was destroyed look I'm sorry your
planet was destroyed oh don't be I'm the
one who destroyed
it initialize cloning machine yes
G so the planet he'll just clone himself
when I was but a squidling I found out
my parents
were no child should ever have to endure
that and soon thereafter was married
things were going well until she wanted
to and then I was all no way and she was
all yes way and I was
like
but I've told you too much
already let the birth of my new planet
galaxa
[Music]
begin so it's just a bunch of hmns okay
the planet is just clones of him a UFO
has landed in America
UFO humans of Earth I have come in peace
I mean you no harm however it is
important to note that most of you will
not survive the next 24
hours I think that's raen Wilson oh yes
I think you're
right wow they're really dead I guess
maybe the quantum Monaco could solve cuz
we're not going to let insecto die in
vain we're going to get up there find
Susan and we're going to take that alien
down yeah you got enough juice in those
jetpacks to get you up there but not
enough to make it home I'll come get you
if I can what do we do that's a sign of
respect oh they each get jetpacks I want
a
jetpack I can't shake it I can't shake
him that's what I say after every first
date can't shake
[Applause]
him
uh
that's why I always wear a parachute
Lieutenant no no no not all of you you
there yeah that is rain
willome take the prisoner to the
incinerator she's useless to us now
she's got heart and soul in a brain and
she's going to find her way out of here
how are we supposed to get to her
there's too many of them but I have an
idea
idea this is not going to work it's a
terrible idea it's really bad you guys
really stand out you know that right F I
galaxur command you to hand over the
prisoner Gods take this defective clone
to the incinerator well what are you
waiting for Bob you and you seriously
take the prisoner and the defective
clone to the
incinerator of course sir here's a
security pass just in case mhm would you
like a gun yes I would hey guys
look believe you guys came to save me
thank you he's still holding the we
monsters got to stick together but I'm
not a monster anymore you'll always be
nothing but a filthy carbon based life
form ha G hail
Gala these disguises are the bomb that's
it the only way to save the Earth G the
only way to save
gar the only way to save the Earth is to
blow up this ship before The Invasion
starts we need to find the main power
core could you direct us to the main
power core above the extraction chamber
awesome weapon like this needs to be in
the hands of somebody
responsible hail
galaxa monsters oh no attention all
Aliens destroy all
monsters you want some of
this prove your strength yes you want to
hurt my friends you'll have to go
through
[Applause]
me oh
no right to the
core this little cockroach man is
amazing he never
dies like video game character
[Music]
I can't believe we made it well H
grp oh Bob
yeah
wow that hurt blob did so good om m
g warning Intruder can Bob absorb that
you'll never never figure out my color
codee maybe she can this won't be but a
moment red green blue yellow orange baby
blue purple it's like DDR that looks
awesome tired dance moves are no match
for my security
protocols my PhD is
in Dan
what security protocol
breached ship has been set to
self-destruct in tus 6 minutes well
launch The Invasion then Invasion no
longer possible they are getting through
a lot of this pretty easily prepare my
escape
capsule thought the whole monsters
versus alien side would be a little bit
harder living in what harder harder it's
kind of been uh breezing through this
yes h
g we're not going to make it blob we'll
eat them and then jump real high into
the outer space
and they'll all be
okay oh cool never
mind keep
going no no
no get out of here while you still got
the chance I'm not leaving you guys
rendevu with manga he's outside the ship
waiting for you no Susan you finally
have a chance to get your old life back
no she doesn't want it absorb the
quantum Monaco and then open the doors
yeah
you can't do it female carbon based life
form or Susan not contained what that is
not
Susan oh my God she knows how to roll a
professional rollerblader was that her
career before she became a freak cross
the
earthqu it's like Back to the Future but
instead of hoverboards it's roller
blades
[Music]
she's got double space
boards you could have killed me then we
understand each other now open the doors
and let my friends go let my people go
escape capsule ready for transport have
fun
[Music]
exploding
her name's Susan and she lived with
Derek for a long time she can deal with
him she can deal with him now open the
doors even if I wanted to I couldn't
there's nothing you could do about it
Susan I wouldn't be so sure and the name
is ginor can she shoot herself and
then oh nice okay
[Music]
cool yeah girl get it now she's made the
choice to absorb she has agency it's
been an honor knowing you doc the
feeling's mutual my friend I'll see you
guys tomorrow for
lunch did she catch it she
did
it by Hawkins chck why do I think she's
so much hotter as a
giant she's literally just the same but
bigger
3D total Annihilation that's all right
blob will save you where's B he's
supposed to be
[Music]
here oh my God
yay a yay like MMA you're
alive she's like a full kaaj you're a
butterfly cool three come on come on two
one
no he yells H nothing happened maybe my
[Music]
count a they're being celebrated so cute
we're the Guardians of the
[Music]
Galaxy they got
fans run into blob Daddy ever since you
were a baby I knew that someday you
would you know save the Earth from an
Invasion From Outer Space excuse me
hello coming through how are you oh my
god get the F out of here baby I thought
long and hard about what happened baby
and I want you to know I forgive you
you're cancelled I just got a call from
New York they offered me Network all I
have to do is get an exclusive interview
from you flick him that's amazing is the
camera rolling
absolutely
goodbye Derek she flicked him
yeah see you later
deedle you are a selfish
jerk
escara is slowly making its way to Paris
now who's with me I'm in Count Me In too
yeah did they ever make a sequel of this
monsters go to Paris if they didn't
monsters versus
French goodbye Derek good luck getting
over me uh Bob it's me he's never going
to get
over golden
hour again that two timeing
[Music]
jerk everything was in Golden hour or it
was nighttime and I appreciated it
make sure if you're listening on Apple
or Spotify that you rate US and review
us we would really love
it everyone let's welcome my new
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
General WR Monger what a great way sir
to celebrate my 90th birthday 90th I
have assembled a preliminary budget
estimate for the rebuilding of San
Francisco zers this is going to be a
boring one how do you take it hit me
with a double vent organic chocolate
brownie caramel frappuccino extra hot
with one inch of foam
nonfat time to wave the white flag and
head for the bunker boys let's check on
the situation in 500 years who wants to
freeze my
head
[Music]
3D okay this movie was fun yeah man that
was a lot of fun and hey what hey you
know what's great a word from our
sponsors thank you to GFI for sponsoring
this video and guys I've said it many
times they're my favorite brand to work
with rainly because it's my favorite
product that I consume every single day
they were a partnership that I
personally sought out because I had
already been using their products for
months prior to ever working with them
so I was excited when they were like all
right fine we'll work with you because
you keep begging us too which you guys
can do like I have right here this is a
powder version I got a bunch of
different powders in my in my kitchen
they work just as effective they help me
with my focus my energy G what I love is
that I don't feel like I crash it is
just Pitch Perfect it's a great thing to
mix and also you know it's not an
official pre-workout but I often use it
as a pre-workout as well I love them and
you could use our Link in the
description box to get yourself 20% off
select tubs however um I just wanted to
give a personal message to uh my brand
manager the brand manager over there uh
I won't say his name but recently we
negotiated now you might know a couple
months ago I was like you know what guys
I'll go with a lower rate if you send me
just double the amount of gfuel cans
they agreed to it because why wouldn't
they and now I've even option for that
again I've even asked for less money but
for more cans right now this past week G
fuel rep where are my cans it's been
like 3 days since we had this
conversation and I know that we only
just struck this new deal but I'm
itching for them cans and before you
guys know it I'm taking you on my
journey I'm going to have a year Supply
worth of G fuel cans and I'm pretty sure
that will be the second Studio's
background is just a bunch of cans that
should be recycled I don't know if it's
a good look for gfuel being like hey I
ordered these but then again I have
ordered
about I want to say like six months
worth of G cans it's it's a little
ridiculous now that I think about just
how much I have coming in thank you GF
and oh yes getting them is is a great
way to you know help support the channel
as well because whenever you buy from
them it lets them know you you guys know
how it goes it helps and helps helps us
keep this relationship as well benefits
you too what you think Tara Tara I like
the movie you guys get out of town okay
now listen she comes to find herself and
her true nature she leaves that guy
behind and he's like I choose to be
Giant and I support her she becomes a
strong independent woman who realizes
she don't need a man um which you know
that's like it's like me I'm giant I'm
not giant but like I don't need a man
right I'm a strong independent woman and
um I saw a lot of me and her and I'm
sure she saw a lot of her in me yeah um
for sure uh the casting was
perfect it was really really good I
liked all the voices and um you know me
love me some Reesey she's so she's so
cute and just the best perfectly cast so
good and yes the cameras uh the cameras
the shots in this like the DP and the
the camera angles whoever did camera
assist on this it's good stuff good
stuff long tracking shots one shots I
always appreciate in every movie I
always call that out if it's a long shot
and it's moving yes sir R I'm into it
also love they always shot a golden hour
is nice and pretty in the background
always except for always for most live
the part except for when it was night
and then you You Could See Stars so they
made it pretty at all times Greg I was
getting there that's all I got to say I
think you can you just say your opinion
now what did you not like about
it let me think let me think because I
really wasn't uh I was never was never
really bored during this uh and but I
definitely started thinking about a lot
of other things when I was watching yeah
me too I got distracted thinking I need
to buy or stuff I need to get done in my
life a little bit but like but at the
same time I wasn't mad at it I I was
totally joking were you think was that
really happen I didn't happen is that
what really happened with you I can see
it happening with you for a moment in
time I was like oh you need to get
almond milk on the way home and that was
it that was it was only that one little
thought the rest of the time I was not
bored okay
it I just and I really liked okay I also
liked when she does her whole
um uh Speech to all of them and like you
guys all do these great things uh I like
that little moment it was a little heart
tohe heart to when they truly became a
family and I really like that it was
super cute um there was nothing that I
didn't like that I thought was dumb or
didn't make sense right right it was all
great it was all good
yeah I love the world of this a lot it's
a it's very much a an homage to uh an
earlier era of sci-fi movies it's got
kind of that mix of like Incredibles
meets mega mind I think Dreamworks
Animation uh I I still feel like in a
lot like there's a while where Pixar was
the dominant one and Dream works was
looked at as the secondary one and maybe
that's still as the association just
because of the prestige that Pixar has
right how however I think like
DreamWorks more often than not they
really know how to they really know how
to nail it like sometimes their camera
work is just so phenomenal I don't know
if there's any like the how to train
dragon was something that we really
loved I love the K Fu Panda movies I
love mega mind uh there's a lot of
fantastic uh DreamWorks films and I
don't know if this one did well or not
uh like part of me really got caught up
in that cuz you you notice like oh is
this how she gets her hair white I
didn't even realize I was the same
person and I didn't and I've seen the
poster so many times from Monsters
versus Aliens I don't recall if I've
ever seen the trailer for it no ien
because I really knew nothing about this
movie before going into it other than
like I'm assuming it's about Monsters
and Aliens right I never realized she
was Giant and even looking at the poster
now I'm like oh that did not communicate
to me it it constantly just looked like
a woman like some a woman next to badass
Action Hero with a uh with and I think
the the giant part of it completely gets
lost on the posters and and some of the
marketing unless I'm assuming if you've
seen the trailer and I feel like that's
such an integral thing to communicate
that she is one of the monsters right
you know CU she just looked like lead of
a bunch of cartoony monsters yeah I
agree and I think that might have helped
I don't know if this movie was a hit or
not but I love you're were saying if
they changed the poster to make it look
like she was a monster would have helped
I think it might have effectively
communicated like even for me it
immediately skyrocketed my interest once
I realized oh she is one of the monsters
I thought she was just some like
government Action Hero just based off of
images alone is there something else
after the no okay yeah I thought that's
what what the case might be um but I
loved I I loved her character because I
found myself very uh endeared to her and
I rooted for her and I I just love the
placement of like our monster is
anything but that and and they don't
really like it's a heroine situation for
her but they don't lean into the
darkness in in terms of tone for her
they still kept it very lighthearted yet
I still really I I really rooted for her
and I loved our our core cast of
characters I love the who played the was
that Hugh Lori who played the uh doctor
scientist guy um yeah that sounds
probably right right yeah okay okay the
Dr Cockroach yeah I thought he was great
out of the for he was my second favorite
um and I I liked uh I liked the missing
link Will Arnett's Voice work I I did
kind of like I love them all their
chemistry and their I love their
personalities I did feel like um link
did could have used a couple of more
things that demonstrated his prowess for
the situations at hand so they felt more
like an essential group kind of like a
Guardians of the Galaxy or the suicide
squad where you do see the necessity for
each one of them yeah and Link was one
that if there are moments there but I
think that's the stuff that is the
easiest to overlook or or uh not really
remember because he didn't really get as
many truly shiny moments at zero in on
what necessitates him as part of the
core group right but I like The Voice
work uh Seth Rogan as Bob would kind of
go up and down for me of whether or not
it was funny or not
yeah but sometimes he was super duper
funny uh but overall I just really like
the um science fiction world that in
habits and the overall heart that this
movie has and and yeah the way this film
is shot every every frame just feels so
composed there's like wonderful
throwback music uh throughout and yeah
there just like overall science fiction
flare and the other thing that I did
find myself craving as well I lik the G
I thought galar had some funny moments
that I thought Rift on some cliches like
I love the whole bit or his telling his
back story that was that was very funny
when they're making fun of like how
villains just monologue their backstory
out of nowhere Oh I thought that was
hilarious rain Wilson perfect Voice work
for that character very good A lot of
times characters who get like multiple
eyes often just see in the same
direction so I like how they really paid
attention to the details oh right like
their mve moving around different yeah
yeah they can you can see it like
observing different things at once and
sometimes they do work in unity I did
think though that as much as he's like
Intergalactic genius again that was
something that I feel like they could
have flushed out a little bit more so
that way we I think that's when I was I
wasn't checking out necessarily but I I
did like the at the times I was having
the most fun and found this the most
exciting was before they got on his ship
yeah agreed before the team got there
because I I weirdly felt like this is
when the stakes should be the most
ramped up but they're kind of getting
through things in a in kind of just a
funny quick way and I'm I'm losing some
of the threat of galar yeah because
remember the very first thing I was like
that was quick when they got the gun
they killed the guy and they like thanks
for saving me guys I was like oh okay
I'll give you one joke I'll give you
like one joke find then was like that's
kind of just how like oh the brain how
are we going to do this I'm going to do
a dance off thing you know I just kind
of kept going through it quickly and so
I thought the threat level of him which
when you're calling it Monsters versus
Aliens I think they really could have
used a little bit more of the threat of
the aliens side but in terms of them
attempt was there a sequel to do you
know terara I don't know monsters versus
I don't know anything really sequel
let's just type it in I don't know
sequel the film started a franchise with
a video game and I could see that being
uh the case cuz there there there were
parts of it that felt like video game
levels and the way they worked as a team
and I and I don't know what the game
looks like I'm learning this for the
first time right now but I could if you
tell me they made a video game like yeah
I absolutely could see that cuz there
were parts that totally reminded me of a
video game yeah but I imagine what they
were trying to do was set up a franchise
and like like a Marvel movie or a number
of superhero films when you're setting
up the team it's like yeah I really like
the protagonist I really like the core
characters they got a great back in
fourth their team of Misfits and I love
them coming together villains a little
weak but the main core characters and
maybe they can improve upon the villains
in a sequel and that's kind of where I'm
sitting here is like that was the vibe
the movie left me with but I feel like
that's what DreamWorks does cuz
DreamWorks make Madagascar right yeah
I've been watching that with John and my
my main complaint and is that that
DreamWorks doesn't really hit it hard
they always keep it kind of light and
there's not enough like heart
or danger that's true that
one that got me that was like amazing
but in the Madagascar and in this one I
mean we we do get a heart like a little
bit there when um when she's given the
talk to them and she's I like that she
found out on her own that dererk is a
jerk right she just kind of sits there
and is like no one had to tell her or
convince her or be like hey girl listen
up he's a jerk and he's selfish like she
just realized it on her own which I
really like that character character
development uh for her character
specifically I really enjoyed that um
and I I liked that part that part was
like had heart and some emotion in it
which was cool the rest of it was like
yeah just kind of like light and Airy is
I feel like how DreamWorks does it which
I have you seen Kung Fu Panda yes a long
time ago I don't think I've seen there's
is there multiple the second one's my
favorite and the second one gets a lot
like that the second one it slaps hard
yeah yeah they go they go there with
some and those are the kind of
films I like like hit it hard make me
feel some stuff have you not seen have
you seen mega mind I I don't make pry
pretty I no I get it like like I felt I
felt off the Ice Age franchise um pretty
early on yeah I like I stopped Shrek
after Trek 3 so no I get it like there's
a lot of DreamWorks movies I just have
completely skipped yeah like if you
can't pull me in with the emotions and
like the plot line that I'm not I'm I'm
thinking about almond milk you know but
I was very much uh connected to uh what
was her Susan Susan like and it's really
cool because they didn't they didn't
really set her up a lot of times in
these movies what what they'll do is all
right let's give Susan some like
terrible personal life before and they
didn't really give her like this sure
she was clearly Maring a narcissist but
that was about it U which is not good
but they didn't do this whole thing
where like her parents disapprove of her
or she's had some traumatic backstory or
some right right they they kept
it relatively simple and the the pain
inflicted on her is the tragedy of
having the
meteorite um you know take over her body
and become this GI so I I thought like
making that the core the the wound for
her to deal with was made it very
compelling that also thrust the plot
forward so I was very much connected to
her like when she's trying to run away
during the city and is scared and then
she starts finding her strength
naturally from protecting these people I
thought was like that was such a an
amazing sequence to me I thought that
entire sequence both visually and
emotionality wise and the way they
capture the scale and the scope of
everything I thought was excellent um
even when she's sort of becoming more
embracing the monster when she's
attacking gacasa whatever his name is
uh the way how they switched that where
he's running away from her yeah to the
point of view where she now is the
monster yeah I thought that was
excellent yeah um so yeah I really I
really loved all that and and um and I
forgot what the like I was doing that
thing where I'm talking and I'm like
giving a lot of Praise so that way I
could lead into some other criticism I
had and I completely I completely forgot
what the criticism was for he thinks
it's perfect yeah I mean the movie I I
really thought it was great like I
really did I wonder what the I wonder
what the critic score is on did a great
job especially when um she finally gets
to the bridge and the way that she
becomes a hero is by saving people which
is great that you know it wasn't just
saving her friends like the monsters it
was like oh these people are in danger
and she is now choosing to be not even
choosing with her realizing it but she's
now a monster who's going to become a
hero and like her friends are going to
only want to be on her team because
she's shown so much strength and bravery
that they didn't really have until she
got there um and I think she's only
raised them up and now they're going to
go kick some butt but they didn't make
another one so yeah man thought was
great special effects surprisingly low
audience score that's surprising yeah it
was pretty low 59% people didn't really
love it very much that's that's
surprisingly low for this movie I feel
like a lot of more love has come around
for it yeah maybe that's just well it
does say 200 50,000 ra yeah it's true
it's a lot of people that's insane
that's a lot of people rating this movie
interesting I wonder I wonder why
Monsters versus Aliens a box office
though I wanted to see if this was a
hidden Z like it did pretty well oh they
good they dou doubled the budget how did
it not get a sequel hm cuz people didn't
like it I don't know or they just well
it became a TV show they said they they
turned it into a video game and then
then also a TV show and apparently
insecto side is not in it and people are
like why isn't inecto in it um I read
that while you were scrolling I'm a
quick reader um okay so I mean I don't
know but anyway no oh I think it's the
worldwide grow so it's not enough oh
yeah so
maybe that was just yeah if it was just
domestic yeah that's not good enough but
no the fan base has definitely come
around for it but overall no I mean
still really enjoyed it and from the
imagery I would see from posters and
whatever little screenshots I would
catch I thought the visuals were way
like I was never really drawn to seeing
this movie because I would see like a
poster or something and I was like this
looks like too kidy for me and I was
agree I was surprised by how visually
striking the movie actually was and how
good the special effects were like that
was the main thing that was I I thought
this was going to look like so bad but
yeah that was Sur surprising but in
terms of being like a Sci-Fi comedy I
think like it it made me laugh plenty
for a family film surprisingly crass
humor at times and for sci-fi and
animated movie I thought they really
leaned into a lot of great Omas oh I
like the general guy too I thought he
was really yeah that was kefir that was
Keir that was kefir I knew it right away
cuz I love him and I love that show 24 I
was watching that when I was like six
that's when that that show came out when
I was six sure I was six you keep
telling the casting directors who watch
this that that's that's the reality of
the situation I'm only
22 I have so many youthful years
left um anyway okay we should stop
joking about your age yeah I see it's
starting to get to
you is it yeah I mean I feel fine right
now yeah okay the only one getting to
me is me I mean Terry you look great
thank you dot dot dot I wore purple
today for your age yeah yeah
exactly okay listen do you have anything
more to say yeah I would give this movie
a seven out of 10 oh really I'd bump it
to like a 7.85 look at him go look at
him thriving he's flying he's flying 7.8
I'm going to stick what did I say a
seven I said a seven it was 10 seconds
went by and I already was like what um
these are issues that I have to deal
with
and that you also have to deal with if
you're watching this or listening on
Apple or Spotify close us out yeah yeah
okay great we love you leave a like
leave a comment be cool nice kind and
also subscribe if you haven't already
join patreon we love you so much and we
will see you on the next one
goodbye this is for the
sink oh man how do your ears not hurt
what